Opposers, I work very hard
preparing this show.
I think it shows.
But like any elite athletes,
I need a break
every now and then.
So I'm going to take this time
to catch up
on some of my relaxing
court mandated art therapy--
painting--
and I'm going to respond
to some calls
from loyal Opposers.
Now, these have been gathered
by my crew,
and I have not had a chance
to listen to them
until this very moment,
but I'm sure they've all been
screened for profanity
and this segment
will be a total success, so...
Chuck, let's fire up
the first call, shall we?
-(phone beeps)
-MAN: Uh, yes, hello, Jordan.
-Hello.
-This is Neil from Miami.
I got into a fight recently
with my dad,
who says you're
a conspiracy theorist.
And I think you're not one,
and now I'm never gonna speak
to him again.
So how do you deal
with situations like this
-when you disagree with your
family members? -Neil...
Neil, great question.
First of all,
I am not a conspiracy theorist.
Secondly, are you sure
that's your dad?
(laughter and applause)
Just 'cause even just
from the tenor of your voice,
I feel like
there's something amiss,
and something that most fathers
should have inside
is complete love and affection
and care and trust
in their child.
If that's something
you don't get
when you're small
and growing up,
it can lead to some cracks
in your life
that you have to spackle over
with things like fear
and anger and bullshit.
And you wouldn't wish that
on anybody
'cause it could turn them
into a (bleep) monster.
(laughter)
I'm saying maybe just talk
to your dad a little more.
Let's get back to this painting.
Chuck, give me another call.
-(phone beeps)
-Hey, Jordan. This is Charlie
-from Bristol, Rhode Island.
-Okay.
I got to say,
I was just on vacation.
I had this sandwich-- a falafel.
Have you had this thing?
It was hot,
it was crispy, it was delicious.
And I got to say, I'm worried,
'cause if this thing
makes it over to our shores
across the oceans and whatnot,
this thing could take over.
You know, like-like a plague.
And I'm sort of worried
about hot dogs
and what's gonna happen to them,
because I love those,
and I don't want
to see them-them go away,
but I can't get this taste
out of my brain.
So, uh, you know, I'd love
to hear what you've got to say.
It was probably a BLT.
Next call.
-(phone beeps) -Yeah, Jordan,
this is Chelsea from Cleveland,
and I was just wondering
what the worst state is
in our country.
I mean,
I would say probably Canada,
but I'm open to your opinion.
I mean, California,
New York City--
what's the worst one?
Yeah. The worst state?
Denial.
And no, it's not just
a river in Sudan.
(scoffs)
(laughter and applause)
All I can tell you
is wake up and understand
the worst state is New York
combined with California.
Next call.
-(phone beeps)
-WOMAN: Hey, Jordan.
-Yeah. -It is Mary
from Morgan Hill, California,
Bay Area strong, and I had a...
Like, what is this Russia thing?
Like, am I supposed
to love them, hate them?
Like, they're...
I just don't know if...
what we're supposed to do,
Jordan.
Oh, by the way, Putin--
super cute.
Like, how old is he?
He's not, like, dad age, right?
Like... younger.
I-I don't know. Fangirl.
Great.
Russia's a confusing thing.
I think you need to think
of Russia as a weapon.
Uh, do they attack America?
Perhaps.
In which case, Russia bad.
Do they support Trump-a?
Trump? Trump-a?
Um...
You know,
you might take that as a slip-up
that makes it sound
like I've taken the word "pa,"
which means "father,"
and I've attached it to "Trump,"
which means "leader,"
and then I've connected
those two things subconsciously
because there's some hole
because I-I'm missing something
with my father.
(laughter)
That there's a crack
deep inside,
that there's a connection
that I didn't have
when I was small,
and so in moments of stress,
where, perhaps, I'm reaching,
I take those feelings,
and I connect them
to other authority figures,
and they slip out,
and they reveal something
about myself.
But you'll never get inside.
(laughter and applause)
So, I think
we're running out of time,
and I got to go clear some space
in my bathroom to hang this guy.
But I think it's coming along
pretty well.